There are plenty of horror stories that begin
innocuously enough.
A new home, a camping trip with friends, a
doll purchased at an estate sale….
This one starts with some ponds, the same
set of ponds that James, our master of microscopes,
has been sampling every week for the past
three years.
Which means that he’s collected so many
microbes from these waters that you might
think they’d get a bit boring or redundant.
But you should never underestimate nature’s
capacity for surprise.
Recently, James came home with some samples
from these ponds.
And as usual, he prepared some slides and
checked on the organisms within, finding some
nematodes like this one slithering about on
the slide.
And all seemed well, so he stored the slides
and his new friends in a humidity chamber
and waited to observe them after a few more
days.
But two days later, all would not be well.
This is where we build our suspense.
In a movie, this would be the moment where
we assess the unsettling basement or the dark
woods, and then consider retreating to safety.
This is the creepy doll, only there hasn’t
been any thumps in the middle of the night,
so everything seems okay, right?
We’re looking at the spores of a fungus,
one belonging to the group Arthrobotrys.
And when it’s just floating around like
this, it seems quite harmless—especially
when compared to the nematodes we showed earlier,
which are part of a whole family of worms
that are notorious for their parasitic lifestyle.
And if you were to write off Arthrobotrys
as a potential threat, you would be correct…most
of the time.
It does spend much of its life aligned with
the dead, but only to sustain itself on the
remains of decayed life and organic matter.
Arthrobotrys species are found all around
the world, occupying everything from soil
to animal feces in the many varied climates
that make up our planet.
And wherever it is, the fungus ensures that
nutrients like nitrogen from dead organisms
and other waste cycle through ecosystems.
But when nitrogen is scarce, these fungi will
resort to hunting it down from living sources.
And what better prey than the nematode, a
fellow dweller of the soil and one of the
most abundant animals on earth?
When James put his slides into the humidity
chamber, he had no notion of what these nematodes
would be facing, and so no expectation of
what he would find.
But when the slides came back out, what he
observed was something he’d only seen once
before, in a drawing done two years ago by
one of his close friends, Katelyn Solbakk.
In it, you can see a nematode whose body has
been clinched into segments by some kind of
bulbous...thing.
What you’re seeing is the fungus’ most
brutal design.
But to get there, it must morph from decomposer
to predator—no longer consuming what has
already been dead, but actively killing.
It begins by weaving a trap out of itself.
It threads the hyphae of its mycelium out
and then back in, forming a living loop that
repeats to form a net.
But a net is only one part of a trap—the
other part is the lure.
The fungi can find nematodes by following
traces of their pheromones like they’re
breadcrumbs.
And more nefariously, they can mimic the smell
of certain food cues to draw the worm in,
like a siren working through scent instead
of song.
The nematode has no reason to suspect anything,
even as it swims closer and closer and eventually
through the fungal rings.
But as it does, the movement of worm and water
triggers the rings to constrict.
The worm is trapped, but the worst is still
yet to come.
The fungus’ hyphae begin to grow off from
the loop, puncturing the worm’s cuticle
and paralyzing it.
The threads swell up into a bulb that produces
more hyphae to spread through the rest of
the nematode.
And then the fungus feeds and feeds, quickly
digesting the rest of the nematode’s body
from within.
It is a gruesome death.
Here is one nematode, just recently trapped.
And here is the worm again, four days later.
You can see the infection bulb where the fungus
first punctured and expanded.
And the whole body of the worm seems taken
over, no longer a clear tube, but instead
a corpse that has become home to its cause
of death.
The Arthrobotrys fungi are not the only ones
capable of trapping and feeding upon nematodes.
There is a whole range of nematode-trapping
fungi with their own methods, though the species
Arthrobotrys oligospora is perhaps the most
plentiful of these fungi and also the best
studied.
Maybe it’s just us, but it’s somewhat
unsettling to realize that this insidiousness
is all the work of a fungus, a thing that
can seem so inert compared to the wiggling,
active worm that it targets.
But fungi do have a kinship with horror stories.
Their frequent role as decomposers naturally
connects them with the dead.
Plus, they come equipped with their own creeping
sense of dread with images of mycelia weaving
through bodies.
And authors have drawn inspiration from the
notion of fungal horror.
There are many works--like the famous Gothic
tale We Have Always Lived in the Castle, or
the short story “The Voice in the Night,”
or recent novels like Mexican Gothic and Wanderers—
that draw on everything from poisonous mushrooms
to colonizing fungi to create their terror.
But whatever we seek to scare ourselves with
in fiction, horror has its purpose in nature.
As we’ve pointed out, nematodes are one
of the most abundant animals on earth.
They play an important role in decomposition...but
they’re also the source of many diseases—both
in animal bodies and in plants.
So having them be slightly less abundant is
important to our ecosystem as well.
In fact, scientists have been studying these
fungi to develop better nematode-fighting
strategies for agriculture.
So as is the case with many good horror villains,
there is a version of this story where the
nematode-trapping fungus is the hero.
Unless, of course, you’re the nematode.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds
us.
And of course, thank you to all of the people
on this screen right now.
If you like this show, these are the folks
you should be thanking.
They are our patrons on patreon and you can
become one of them by going to Patreon.com/journeytomicro.
Thank you so much to everyone who’s been
able to do that.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James Weiss, check out Jam & Germs
on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.